Hallo Guten Tag, gün görmez mein Name, gün görmez ist mein Name. Ich bin heute in dieser Station,
die NSWH Bende und für die 3. Niga erst und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen eine Analympie
WHOMAS wieder mit Jungs Vornamen. Thomas.
Hör Thomas, spreche ich richtig aus? Ja, auch richtig.
Okay, wann sind Sie genau geboren? Am 7.02.1997. Könnten Sie bitte wiederholen?
Am 7.02.1997. Wie alt sind Sie? 28.
Schon wärst du. Wie groß sind Sie? 1.74. Wie wiegen Sie?
Wie viel? Wie viel? Ja, so knapp 80 Kilo 79, 80.
Okay, wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt? Das ist Dr. Seva.
Wegen wir. Und was führt Sie für uns?
Ja, wissen Sie, mein Freund hat mich jetzt ja hier begleitet. Ich bin vorhin mit einem Fahrrad
im Gefahren. Ich bin gefahren und ich hatte zwar den Helm auf, aber ich habe auch meine Brille getragen
und es hat mir einmal ganz doll geregnet. Und dann war meine Brille so beschlagen und so
nass und dann habe ich einen Board steinig richtig gesehen und bin da voll drauf gefahren.
Und da hat es mich umgehauen. Ich bin auch die linke Seite gefallen.
Ich habe dann noch versucht zu bremsen, aber irgendwie das geht ja alles ja so schnell.
Pengen lag ich auf dem Boden.
Wann ist das passiert?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange das her ist. Vor einer Stunde, mein Freund hat mich dann erst nach Hause gebracht,
aber ich habe mich dann einmal übergeben und ich war da auch für einen ganz kleinen Augenblick
nach seinen Aussagen. Weil ich bewusstlos und ich kann auch wirklich nicht mehr so genau sagen,
was da alles passiert ist. Ich bin glaube ich ein paar Minuten weg gewesen.
Also fehlt mir das die Erinnerung.
Ja, und Sie haben gesagt, bewusstlos zu sein.
Ja, ja, ja.
Und jetzt ist mir halt schlecht und mir tut die ganze Seite weh.
Ich habe natürlich einen Haufen blau aufs Schlecke. Das ist sehr sofort losgegangen.
Das habe ich gemerkt.
Haben Sie Ihr Kopf gestoßen?
Ja, ich hatte zwar den Helm auf, aber ich bin mit dem Kopf aufgekommen.
Und ich habe jetzt auch so ein bisschen dröhnen Kopf.
Der linke Oberarm tut mir sehr stark weh.
Den kann ich irgendwie auch nicht richtig bewegen.
Und der Bauch tut mir auch weh.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe mich richtig derbe hingelegt.
Sie haben auch Bauchschmerzen und linke Armschmerzen.
Der Oberarm tut mir ganz aber, ja, ich habe das Gefühl,
dass ich den gar nicht belasten kann.
Wo ist Ihre Bauchschmerzen ganz genau?
Linke Seite oder?
Ja, ich würde schon sagen, vielleicht, also so im Oberbauch,
aber ja, eigentlich schon in der Mitte,
vielleicht ein bisschen nach links, da wo ich auch aufgeprallt bin oder so.
Vielleicht auch mit den Rippen weh tun oder so.
Aber überwiegend habe ich eigentlich mehr das Gefühl,
dass der Bauch weh tut.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen dort eine Perellung oder?
Ja, ich bin blitzeblau.
Also das merke ich jetzt schon, dass es alles blau wird auf der Seite.
Das tut alles weh.
Okay.
Wo hat Schmerz in ober, linken Oberarm,
da tut es doldweh, ja, an der Außenseite so.
Haben Sie Schmerz im Ellenbogen?
Im Ellenbogen, nicht im Oberarm.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Und habe ich richtig verstanden, Sie haben erst einmal erbrechen.
Ja, ich musste mich einmal übergeben.
Ja, ja.
Und schlecht ist mir jetzt eigentlich auch so ein bisschen.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Und während der Situation, gibt es dort jemand,
gab es Zeugen?
Zeugen?
Ja, mein Freund war halt hinter mir mit dem Fahrrad.
Ja, und der hat mich auch aufgesammelt dann.
Beziehungsweise, der hat dann eben auch registriert,
dass ich kurz weggetreten war.
Und er hat mich dann auch nach Hause gebracht.
Und er hat mich mit dem Auto dann hierher gebracht.
Okay, haben Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Ja.
Und jetzt, ja, dann können Sie nach der Umfalt,
konnten Sie ruhig laufen oder gehen oder?
Ja, ich habe schon, aber mir ist so ein bisschen schwindelig gewesen.
Ja, und jetzt ist mir eigentlich auch so ein bisschen schwindelig.
Jetzt haben Sie auch schwindelig.
Ja, ich sitze jetzt, aber wenn ich jetzt laufen müsste,
würde ich mich lieber irgendwo mit der rechten Hand festhalten.
Und haben Sie Sehprobleme?
Sehprobleme?
Nein, eigentlich, also gucken kann ich schon.
Also ich hatte bei einem Unfall Sehprobleme,
weil meine Brille halt nass war, nicht?
Deswegen ist es überhaupt passiert.
Okay, und können Sie Ihre Glitmaßung ruhig bewegen oder?
Ja, also das linke Bein tut beim Laufen natürlich schon ein bisschen weh.
Da habe ich sicherlich irgendwelche fettenblauen Flecken.
Und den linken Armen kann ich, würde ich sagen,
so würde ich nicht versuchen zu bewegen.
Das tut unheimlich weh.
Okay, im Schulter haben Sie Schmerzen?
Nein, im Oberarm.
Oberarm, okay.
Und haben Sie irgendwo Wunde oder offenen Wunde?
Hab ich jetzt nicht genau gesehen,
vielleicht ist ein bisschen an den Bein oder an der Hüfte aufgeschürfen.
Ich habe nicht so genau geguckt, weil ich halt jetzt andere Probleme.
Okay, haben Sie geblutet?
Nein.
Ich habe das nicht gesehen, dass es geblutet hätte irgendwo.
Okay.
Und haben Sie irgendeine Verzerrallergie,
oder Medikamente, oder irgendeine Verzerrallergie?
Nein, ich habe eine krasser Allergie gegen Bienenstiche.
Deswegen habe ich auch einen Adrenalin-Pen immer bei mir.
Aber im Augenblick ist ja nichts mit Bienen,
viel zu nass dafür zum Glück.
Ja, aber sonst auf Medikamente wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Ich habe mir auch eine Unverträglichkeit gegen Milch,
gegen Ernehmung.
Ich habe einen Lebensmittelmüll, kann alles essen, was ich will.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Pille?
Ja, natürlich, klar.
Aber ist es möglich, Schwanger zu sein?
Deswegen nehme ich ja die Pille. Nein, ich hoffe nicht.
Ja, okay.
Und haben Sie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen bei Ihnen?
Ja, ich habe eine bekannte Hashimoto-Touriolisis.
Also, das hat man vor zehn Jahren festgestellt.
Ich bin also in der Unterfunktion und muss Elgeroxin nehmen.
Wie viel Minigran?
75 morgens nehme ich da.
Da muss ich halt auch regelmäßig zur Kontrolle.
Und haben Sie irgendwelche Blutgerinselkrankheiten oder irgendwelche Probleme mit Blutung?
Ja, bisher nicht. Das bleibt so.
Okay. Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Ja, klar.
Was Sie gesagt haben, die Pille und das elteroxin.
Und weil wir darf, nehme ich auch Ibuprofen, wenn ich Kopfschmerzen habe oder so.
Das hilft mir immer ganz gut.
Wie oft bekommen Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, einmal im Monat oder so.
Und Sie haben irgendwelche Operiert?
Operiert worden? Nein, bin ich bisher in meinem Leben noch nicht.
Auch ambulant oder mit Erdbeutelbunk?
Sie haben das gemacht.
Ihr Mann denn...
Ist doch alles drin?
Alle drin, ja.
Ja, früher hat man ständig blind einmal rausgemacht, aber das macht man gar nicht mehr so oft.
Okay. Und rauchen Sie?
Ne, das habe ich zum Glück nie gemacht.
Haben Sie geraten?
Ne, noch nie.
Und überzeust ihr nicht drauf, aber ja.
Ja, das ist gut für Sie.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Selten. Also ich trinke ruhig mal abends ein Bier.
Oder wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt, auch mal ein Glas Sekt oder ein Glas Wein.
Oder zum Guten Essen.
Aber das kommt nicht so oft vor.
Wann haben Sie letztlich Alkohol getrunken?
Heute? Nein, am Wochenende.
Wochenende, okay.
Wie viel trinken Sie, wenn Sie trinken?
Wenn ich trinke, auch in Masen.
Wenn ich zwei Gläser Wein trinke, ist das schon viel.
Oder anderthalb Glas Bier, meistens langt mir das schon.
Für vollständige kranken Geschichte
muss ich Ihnen nach Drogenkonsum fragen.
Das ist eine routine Frage.
Nehmen Sie bitte nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ne, also wirklich nicht nein.
Und bei Ihrer Eltern ist bei Ihrer Eltern
eine chronische Krankheit oder erbliche Krankheit bekannt?
Also, meine Mutter ist mein, ich quitsch gesund.
Und mein Vater hatte tatsächlich ein bisschen Herzprobleme.
Der hatte vor, das ist gar nicht lange her, vor zwei Monaten,
hatte eine Bypass-Operation.
Okay, und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe eine Zwillingsschwester.
Und ist sie gesund?
Ja, leider ist sie nicht gesund,
die leidet an einer ausgeprägten Depression.
Leben Sie allein?
Ich wohne in der WG.
Ich bin Studentin und lege und wohne halt mit mehreren Dorten zusammen.
Okay, studieren Sie?
Ich studiere noch, ja.
Welche Fach?
Geografie und Literatur.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Studium?
Ja, beim Studium hat man immer Stress,
wenn man Prüfungen machen muss, klar.
Und ja, ich habe Ihnen alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie an mich Fragen?
Ja, das jetzt wohl alles kaputt ist und wie wir jetzt weiter vorgehen.
Ja, ich möchte erst mal Sie ganz genau untersuchen.
Wir brauchen einige suzessliche Bildgebende.
Was ist das zum Beispiel?
Ja, das Röntgen und Tomografie möchte ich Ihnen durchführen.
Sie haben einige Minuten unmächtig gewesen.
Ich bin einige Minuten unmächtig gewesen, ja.
Deswegen möchte ich eine Geheimtomografie durchführen.
Ist das Schmerzhaft?
Nein, das ist nicht Schmerzhaft.
Das ist aber mit Radjax.
Ein Strahlensuntersuch?
Ja, Strahlensuntersuch.
Aber wird nur in der Hauptuntersuch?
Ja, nur in der Kopf und Gehirn.
Diese Untersuchung hat ein bisschen Schicht, Strahlung.
Aber Sie haben, sie sorgen, sie machen sie keine Sorgen.
Das ist einfacher Untersuchung.
Und möchte ich bei Ihnen auch Röntgenuntersuchung in Ihrer Oberanfekt durchführen?
Ja, das ist glaube ich eine gute Idee.
Und er tut mir wirklich sehr doll weh.
Ja, und Untersuchung für Ihren Bauch möchte ich durchführen.
Das ist ohne Strahlhaubende Untersuchung.
Und auch möchte ich Blut abnehmen.
Ja, danach kann ich alle Ergebnisse über alle Ergebnisse sprechen.
Ja, das klingt vernünftig.
Dann muss ich heute nach dem Krankenhaus bleiben.
Ja, das hängt davon ab, wie Ihre Ergebnisse der Untersuchungen sind.
Okay, dann bin ich bei Geduldig und warte ab.
Bitte schön.
Ja, jemand noch weitere Fragen?
Ich hatte eine Frage.
Vielleicht haben Sie im Urin Blut bemerkt?
Ich war auf der Toilette, aber ich habe nicht so genau hingeguckt.
Kann ich nicht sagen.
Ich glaube aber nicht.
Ich wäre mir vielleicht aufgefallen.
Oder gibt es irgendwelche Auffälligkeiten beim Müssenlösen oder mit Deichstuhlkungen?
Normalerweise meinen Sie.
Normalerweise habe ich Verstopfung.
Noch eine Frage.
Vielleicht ist Ihnen aufgefallen,
vielleicht Kribbeln oder Top-Alsgefühl in Ihrer Arme?
Oder Kribbeln?
Kribbeln tut es eigentlich nicht.
Das sind richtig dolle Schmerzen.
Aber Kribbeln tut es eigentlich nicht.
Oder Lähmungerscheinung?
Bitte?
Die Finger kann ich bewegen, aber es tut ein bisschen weh.
Ich halte den Arm eigentlich lieber ganz still,
damit ich den nicht bewege, weil es schon sehr stark weh tut.
Vielen Dank.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie Herzklopfen?
Oder fühlen Sie sich nöder?
Ich fühle mich jetzt ein bisschen schlapp, weil mir so schlecht ist.
Herzklopfen ist mir, ich glaube direkt nach dem Unfall
habe ich bestimmte Herzklopfen gehabt, weil ich mich erschrocken habe.
Aber jetzt würde ich sagen, das schlägt mir nicht bis zum Hals.
Oder so merke ich nicht.
Danke schön.
Wir haben zwei Fragen.
Leiden Sie unter Luftnot?
Luft kriege ich.
Also tief atmen kann ich.
Es tut ein bisschen weh im Bauch,
wenn ich so versuche, so ganz tief einzuatmen.
Aber sonst eigentlich nicht.
Und die andere Frage, also wie stark sind die Schmerzen am Arm?
Auf eine Schmerz, aber von 1 bis 10.
Leichtem 10, sehr starken Schmerzen.
Also viel mehr kann ich nicht aushalten.
Ich würde sagen, die sind zwischen 7 und 8.
Das tut schon saumäßig weh.
Also wenn ich bewege, wenn ich still halte, geht es.
Aber sobald ich das ein bisschen rühre, dann tut es richtig doll weh.
Danke.
Dr. Günge, was Sie sagen? Bescheid, wenn Sie soweit sind.
Okay, danke.
Ich kann versuren.
Darf ich?
Hallo Frau Oberarzt.
Mein Name ist Günge Hermes.
Ich würde Ihnen einen neuen Fall vorstellen.
Haben Sie seit für mich.
Eine neue Patientin vorstellen.
Ja, neue Patientin vorstellen.
Haben Sie seit für mich?
Die Patientin ist für 1 Stunde.
Haben Sie für mich erstmal Personalien?
Ja, okay.
Die Patientin heißt Claudia Thomas.
Geburtstattung ist 7.
2.
1997.
Sie ist 28 Jahre alt.
Und 1 Meter 74 groß.
Und ungefähr 80 Kilogramm.
Und schwer.
Ja, die Patientin ist für 1 Stunde von Fahrrad hingefallen.
Und hingefallen.
Über linken Seite.
Auf die linke Seite.
Auf linken Seite.
Und wie ist das passiert?
Ja, ich habe nicht gefragt.
Er hat es auch mal erzählt.
Ja, ich kann nachfragen bei Unterstudium.
Ja, und ja, Ihre Freundin
ist dort.
Und die Patientin hat einige Minuten
seine Kappe gehabt.
Und die Patientin hat momentan
Kopfschmerzen.
Sie hat auch
linken Oberarmschmerzen.
Und dort
hat sie auch auf der linken Seite
Kopfschmerzen.
Hat sie den Helm getragen?
Ja, sie hat
einen Helm getragen.
Und die Patientin
leidet
über Bauchschmerzen.
Leidet unter Bauchschmerzen,
oder sie klagt über Bauchschmerzen?
Ja, sie klagt über Oberbauchschmerzen.
Und im Oberbau
hat sie eine Prälung
im Oberarm.
Was? Im Oberarm im Bauchschmerz?
Nein, das passt nicht.
Wo hat sie Schmerzen?
Im Oberbau.
Und im Oberarm.
Ja, okay.
Sie hat
einmal
erbrechen.
Erbrochen?
Sie hat sich übergeben?
Ja.
Und sie
hat
sie
vor Erkrankungen
hergezutreitet.
Sie nimmt regelmäßig 75 Milligramm
Erdtrucksin ein.
Und bei Bedarf
nimmt sie
Ibuprofen ein.
Und sie hat
Biene stecke Allergie.
Deswegen trägt sie
immer
Adrenalin-Ejection.
Ja, so ein Pen bei sich.
Für Notfallsicherung.
Und die
Anamnese ist unaufgängig.
Bei der Familienanamnese
hat der Vater
Herzprobleme
und einmal
bei Pass
operiert.
Die Mutter ist gesund.
Sie lebt
und studiert.
Und lebt mit
ihrer Freundin im Wege.
Und wie ist sie hierhergekommen?
Sie hat hierhergekommen?
Nein, mit seiner
Freundin fußläufig.
Sie hat hierhergekommen?
Ja, mit ihrem Freund.
Zu Fuß.
Was meinen Sie?
Was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose bei der Patientin?
Ich vermute
die Patientin
Mutitutrauma hat.
Ich habe
eine kleine
Erdbeutelung.
Wie sagen wir dazu?
Wir sagen nicht Mutitrauma,
aber sagen
Politrauma.
Was hat sie alles?
Ja, ich
ja, ich
habe eine kleine
Erdbeutelung.
Wo ist Ihr Fokus bei der Untersuchung?
Ja,
auch erstmal möchte ich
Bauchutraschall durchführen.
Und
linke Seite
erstmal
Sie gucken wir erstmal.
Da beschränkt es.
Wo nachgucken Sie?
Ich achte
eine Däformite
oder
ob eine Däformite
Prälung gibt
oder nicht.
Wo soll es
diese Däromation oder Prälung geben?
Wo gucken Sie zuerst?
Ja,
die Patientin ist ja nun
im Untersuchungsraum und vermutlich wird sie ausgezogen.
Ja, sonst können sie sie nicht gut untersuchen.
Und jetzt müssen Sie ja irgendwo hin gucken.
Wo fangen Sie an zu gucken?
Was könnte Däformiert sein?
Wo könnte es Prälung geben?
Im Rippen zum Beispiel.
Auf der rechten Seite?
Auch rechten Seite und linken Seite.
Sie gucken doch erstmal die linke Körperhälfte an
und gucken, wo hat sie überall Prälung?
Sie gucken nach dem Kopf
und sehen, ob sie Blut hat.
Sie haben die Patientin gefragt, ob sie Blut hat.
Sie haben die Hautabschürfung.
Das ist das Erste, was man macht, wenn man guckt.
Man schafft sich einen Überblick.
Jetzt gucken Sie weiter und untersuchen die Patientin.
Und in welcher Hinsicht?
Fangen Sie mit dem Bauch-Ultraschall an.
Ja,
Sie gucken, ob Freihäflusik an dem Bauch ist.
Machen Sie nicht vorher noch irgendetwas anderes?
Ja, es ist eine Riss.
Das wäre eine Wunde.
Ja, eine Wunde.
Das haben Sie ja schon bei der Inspektion gesehen.
Was machen Sie denn noch,
wenn Sie eine politraumatisierte Patientin haben?
Ja, das ist eine Wunde.
Sie haben eine politraumatisierte Patientin.
Erst mal Vitalparameter.
Ja, das.
Liebt Sie denn überhaupt noch?
Sie hat Ihnen zwei Antworten gegeben.
Aber wer ja schon ganz nett, wenn man mal guckt,
wie der Blutdruck ist, wie der Puls ist.
Und wie die Verorftungssättigung ist.
Vielleicht sogar auch ein flinkes Ecker.
Um zu gucken, ob da noch alles gut funktioniert.
Und dann können Sie mit dem Bauch anfangen.
Und können nach dem Bauch gucken.
Und können die Ultraschall-Untersuchung machen.
Und natürlich, klar, gucken Sie auf freie Flüssigkeit im Bauch.
Und haben, worauf, da besonders ein Fokus,
auf welches Organ haben Sie gerade schon gesagt?
Ja, ich beachte zum Beispiel die
Pneumotorax, oder die Pilävriall-Effision.
Und Repenfractur.
Wie könnte meine Rippenfraktur feststellen, auch ohne Rippenbild?
Man kann auch beim Ultraschall feststellen.
Aber es gibt nicht auch Gravitationsgeräusch bei Rippenfrakturen.
Ja, Krippeln, oder?
Krippitation, so ein Geräusch, das ist mir.
Ich meine, das ist auch bei Rippen.
Ja, gut.
Ja, wo nach gucken Sie noch?
Ja, im Oberarm, linke Oberarm.
Kontrolliere ich, ob die Beweglichkeit, zum Beispiel vorne,
und kann man bewegen, oder ob eine Deformite hat.
Gebe alle Deformationen, ja.
Also viele Stellung möglicherweise, ja.
Auch da, auch Hörchen, Knüschgeräusch, Hämatom,
wird Sie mit Sicherheit haben, ja.
Und Geschwörung, auch kann man kontrollieren.
Kann man testen, Radial und Ulnar.
Okay, gut.
Wir haben also jetzt die Diagnostik zum ersten Mal,
die Vitalparameter.
Wir haben den Bauch, und wir haben den Arm schon mal so ein bisschen untergelegt.
Das ist schon mal so vor, so, ich nach der Motto, ist da potenziell was gebrochen.
Was gucken Sie denn noch, wenn Sie an den angeschlagenen Kopf denken?
Ja, ich muss Hals untersuchen, Hals, wir bei Säule untersuchen.
Danach, Kopf muss man palpieren.
Und das machen Sie noch?
Ja, neurologische Untersuchung.
Genau, Pupilreflexe, ne?
Es ist wichtig, und Pupilreflexe.
Und Sensibilität, ob da irgendwas tilt, ja, genau.
Ja.
Gut.
Was machen Sie noch?
Sie haben gesagt, Sie nehmen der Patientin Blut ab.
Haben Sie ihr angekündigt?
Ja, ich ...
kleine Blutbild ...
muss man kontrollieren.
Ja, kann man kleine Blutbild ...
ja, bemerken,
irgendwelche ...
innere Blutung ...
so haben oder nicht.
Mhm.
Und ...
auch ...
Sie haben die Patientin ja mehrfach,
eigentlich nach so Trombose-Risiken gefragt, ne?
Also Sie haben gefragt, ob sie raucht,
ob sie die Pille nimmt.
Pille hat sie bejaht.
So, was ist noch interessant im Zusammenhang mit dem Polytrauma?
Ja, gerenutschparameter,
Parameter kann man bestimmen.
Das sollte man mitbestimmen mit einem kleinen Blutbild.
Ja.
Gut.
Was machen Sie denn mit der Patientin?
Nehmen Sie die stationär auf?
Ja, ich würde gerne stationär aufnehmen.
Warum?
Weil die Patientin ...
einige Minuten bewusstlos sein.
Und warum noch?
Und intrakranial Blutung gefahren hat sie.
Genau.
Und ich möchte ...
ja, ich möchte erst mal 24 Stunden beobachten.
Sehr gut.
Okay, gut.
Potentiell hat sie ja auch eine Komotio.
Wenn sie ...
Sie hat sich übergeben.
Sie ist auf den Kopf gefallen.
Trotz Helm kann sie einen Schlag abgekriegt haben.
Und da müsste man auf alle Fälle eben auch besser überprüfen,
ob sie tatsächlich diese 24 Stunden,
ob es da irgendwelche Verschlechterungen gibt.
Gut, ja, sehr schön.
Ja, was machen Sie noch,
um der Patientin weiterzuhelfen?
Wenn Sie sich stationär aufgenommen haben,
legen Sie sie nur ins Bett und kontrollieren Sie,
oder machen Sie noch was?
Ja, ich würde gerne bewusst kontrollieren.
Ach so, okay, ja.
Kontrollieren regelmäßig.
Die Patientin hat starken Schmerzen in ihrem Oberarm.
Ja.
Und die Autopädä-Konsul?
Ja, beziehungsweise ja,
unfallig-chirurgisches Konsul,
dass sie nach dem Arm gucken.
Aber wegen der Schmerzen, was braucht sie denn noch?
Schmerzmittel.
Ja, man hat gesehen, wer es ist.
Sehr dankbar dafür.
Ja, gut.
Dann, wenn wir jetzt davon ausgehen,
dass sie keine Milztruktur hat,
was müssen wir dann noch machen?
Keine Milztruktur.
Wir gehen davon aus, dass sie keine Milztruktur hat.
Wenn sie eine hat,
müssen wir natürlich ganz anders noch agieren.
Ja, aber wenn sie keine hat,
wenn das sicher ist,
was müssen wir dann noch machen?
Tomografie können wir machen,
so sicher.
Und mit Kontrast?
Die junge Frau,
sie raucht zwar nicht,
aber sie nimmt die Pille,
sie wird ins Bett gelegt.
Sind schon Leute dran gestorben?
Ja,
wegen der Genüksgefahr.
Telefoto-Profilate?
Ja.
Ja, das ist gut.
Ja, gut.
Schauen Sie mal,
wie es mit der Frau Thomas los ist
und untersuchen Sie sie.
Ich möchte nachher ganz gerne informiert werden,
was tatsächlich rausgekommen ist,
was alles kaputt ist
und wo wir behandeln müssen
und wie es weitergeht.
Wir schauen uns die Patientin
nachher noch zusammen auf der Station an.
Ja? Okay.
Gut.
Das war ein bisschen eine schwere Geburt.
Ja, ich war sehr gut.
Trauma ist nicht die Lieblingsding, glaube ich, oder?
Ja,
meine Lieblingsbereich
ist normalerweise Trauma.
Aber ich war nicht so wirklich gemerkt.
Aber hier war ich sehr aufgeregt.
Ich kann überhaupt nicht tun.
Ich bin weit weg.
Ich kann Ihnen überhaupt nicht tun.
Sie müssen gar nicht aufgeregt sein.
Ja, ich kann nicht schwitzen.
Nein, also,
wir sind ja hier,
um voneinander was zu lernen.
Ich lerne auch jedes Mal etwas dazu.
Das ist aber sehr gut.
Also, was mir aufgefallen ist,
Sie haben sprachlich wenig Schwierigkeit angehabt,
beide Anamnes.
Sie haben ziemlich vollständig gefragt,
was mir aufgefallen ist,
was man vielleicht machen müsste,
wenn Sie von der ganzen Geschichte erfahren,
dass die Befragung,
das mit der Patientin passiert ist,
würde man, glaube ich, erst mal unterbrechen,
die Befragung und würde zunächst mal
Vitalparameter untersuchen.
Nicht, dass die Ihnen praktisch während der Befragung
unter den Tisch fällt.
Das würde Ihnen, glaube ich,
in der Prüfung hoch angerechnet werden,
wenn Sie sagen, die Patientin gucke ich mir erst an
und reden wir weiter.
Gut, dann ist mir aufgefallen,
dass Sie in paar Fragen eigentlich
nicht gestellt haben, die so klassisch dazu gehören,
dass es einmal diese vegetative Anamnese,
Sie haben es nicht gefragt normalerweise,
haben Sie Probleme mit Verdauern.
Also, ich persönlich finde diese Frage eigentlich,
in dem zu sagen, man ist auch ein bisschen bescheuert,
und das Hauptproblem ist, dass die jetzt ein Umfall hat.
Ob die jetzt Verdauungsprobleme hatte
oder irgendwelche sonstigen Sachen, ist eigentlich relativ wundbe.
Was interessant ist natürlich,
dass diese Lykotoriosa hat, dass man praktisch gucken muss,
dass die weiter ihre Medikamente bekommt.
Das ist natürlich schon wichtig.
Aber danach haben Sie nicht gefragt
und Sie haben nicht nach dem Impfstatus gefragt.
Das wäre unter Umständen auch interessant,
je nachdem, ob sie jetzt offene Wunden hat
oder nicht auch zu fragen, ob sie der Tätanus-Impfung hat.
Das wäre möglicherweise,
falls sich da eine Verletzung noch irgendwo zeigt,
auch noch interessant.
Gut, was mir aufgefallen ist, sprachlich,
wie gesagt, das war in dem Bereich, war alles ziemlich gut.
Haben Sie sehr viel, haben Sie gefragt.
Sie haben das sehr konsequent gefragt,
aber immer die gleiche Formulierung.
Haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie das, haben Sie jenes.
Und das ist natürlich ein bisschen einschönig.
Und das ist schön, wenn Sie da ein bisschen Variationen reinbringen.
Wenn Sie sagen, ist Ihnen aufgefallen,
dass, was ich, hat Ihre Umgebung bemerkt,
dass, wer hat Sie begleitet,
ist der Person etwas, so, nicht,
dass man so ein bisschen mit verschiedenen Fragestellungen hat.
Was mir dann aufgefallen ist, in dem Moment,
wo die Patienten Sie angesprochen hatten,
gesagt hat, ja, wie geht es denn jetzt weiter?
Was machen wir denn jetzt so?
Da wollten Sie, ihr erklären, was Sie als Nächstes machen.
Da waren Sie aus dem Konzept.
Sie mussten frei formulieren
und da haben Sie ungefähr bei jedem zweiten Wort gesagt.
Das machen wir alle gerne.
Ich mache das selber auch.
Ich mache es nicht ganz so oft wie Sie.
Es ist aber wirklich schon ziemlich auffällig gewesen.
Ja, also versuchen Sie es ein bisschen abzustellen
und ja, seien Sie gefasst auf Frage,
die Ihnen gestellt werden vom Patienten,
dass Sie dann auch eine Antwort geben können.
Ja, dass Sie zum Beispiel sagen können,
ja, das ist eine Untersuchung, die radioaktive Strahlen hat,
aber Sie werden natürlich entsprechend abgeschirmt und geschützt
und es ist keine schmerzhafte Untersuchung.
Und ja, was können wir in der Untersuchung sehen?
Wir können dann genau feststellen,
ob in Ihrem Kopf irgendwelche Veränderungen sind
durch den Unfall, was auch immer.
Gut.
Das setzte sich dann fort,
diese sprachliche Unsicherheit
in diesem Arztgespräch.
Wenn Sie nicht an Ihrem Fragenkatalog leben,
in der freien Formulierung machen Sie grammatikalisch mehr Fehler
und Sie formulieren nicht mehr so flüssig.
Ja, abgesehen davon, dass Sie bestimmte Sachen
auch so ein bisschen Antworten schuldig geblieben sind
auf die Nachfragen
und ja, es gibt doch dieses wunderbare Schema
wie Sie Erstuntersuchung machen.
Körperliche Untersuchung,
unter Beachtung von,
das ist natürlich beim Polytrauma viel, was man beachten muss.
Klar, aber man fängt irgendwo am Kopf an
und hört an den Füßen auf.
Man muss ja erstmal alles angucken.
Das ist ja das Erste.
Hat die eine Beule, blutet die irgendwo,
das, was ich, blutet die,
hat die eine Schürfung, Hautabschürfung
an ihrem Arm, wo es ihr wehtut.
Da steht der Arm schief, ja, ist ja knochen irgendwie erkennen,
weil krumm hat sie eine dicke Beule an der Hüfte,
an den Knie, was auch immer, ja, so.
Und wenn ich das angeguckt habe,
dann tastte ich mich ja weiter vorwärts so.
Also, wie Teilparameter haben wir vorher gemacht, ja.
Und dann geht es ja nach einer gelten Strategie
vorwärts neurologischen Untersuchung, Bauchuntersuchung, ja.
Klar, es ist beim Polytrauma so,
dass der Patient in rapide schlechter geht.
Sind sie unter Zeitdruck, ja.
Dann muss natürlich ganz schnell etwas passieren.
Aber so schlecht ging es der jetzt ja nicht.
Man kann ja hoffen, dass die jetzt nicht
überall den maximal schlimmsten Fall hat.
Ja, also das maximale Ding wäre ja,
dass sie sowohl ein schweres Schädel hier in Trauma hat,
als auch ein gebrochenen Arm,
als auch eine Milchskulptur
und irgendwie freie Flüssigkeit im Bauch,
ja, dann wären sie natürlich verdammt unter Zuchtzwang, ja.
Aber wie gesagt, so schlecht ging es der hier nun auch wieder nicht.
Gut, was noch eine interessante Frage wäre, meine ich,
wenn man so diesen Hintergedanken hat,
wir müssen die vielleicht operieren,
dass man mal nachfragt letzte Mahlzeit.
Wann haben sie denn zuletzt etwas gegessen und getrunken?
Ja, ist interessant.
Wegen Potenzieller.
Narkose.
Und natürlich, ja, wenn wir die Milchskulptur abgeschlossen haben,
nach der, wenn wir sie ins Bett legen,
müssen wir bei einer jungen Patientin eine TVT-Profilaxe machen.
Das war schon klar.
Gut, was war noch?
Ja, das waren eigentlich so die entscheidenden Sachen.
Es waren ein paar grammatikalische Sachen,
da habe ich aber zum Teil gleich korrigiert,
haben sie wahrscheinlich gehört und gemerkt.
Sonst vergesse ich das immer sofort.
Das kann ich mir gar nicht ausschauen.
Und, ja, das waren eigentlich die entscheidenden Sachen.
Ja, gut.
Sie haben noch ein bisschen zart.
Ich habe noch wahrscheinlich 2 Monate.
Insofern seien sie entspannt und haben wir noch eine Gelegenheit.
Da ist Frau Yüksel.
Ich habe schon gehört.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Sehr schön, ich freue mich.
Ich bedanke mich bei Ihnen.
Was haben Sie für ein Fall bekommen?
Die Varticulitis.
Bitte, was?
Das ist sehr gut für mich.
Ein guter Fall.
Die Prüferin waren sehr nett.
Die Atmosphäre war sehr freundlich.
So soll das sein.
Natürlich haben Sie gesagt,
dass man mit anderen Patienten
langsamer zu sprechen muss.
Sie sagen, dass man mit anderen Patienten
langsamer zu sprechen ist.
Ich freue mich auch sehr,
dass Sie sich heute Abend persönlich
noch mal zugeschaltet haben.
Ich freue mich sehr,
Sie wünschen Ihnen alles Gute für die nächsten Schritte.
Dr. Güngers,
da kommt schon der Beifall.
Ich bin nicht immer nur nett,
aber Sie wissen, aus der Ferne kann ich nichts tun.
Dr. Güngers hat es heute auch gesehen.
Ich kann Ihnen nicht wirklich etwas tun.
Ich bin sehr froh,
dass Sie uns heute Abend mit einer Beifall haben.
Ich freue mich sehr, dass Sie uns heute Abend
mit einer Beifall haben.
Wir sehen uns am Donnerstag wieder.
Ich freue mich sehr über die erfolgreiche Geschichte.
Ich möchte gerne mehr erfolgreiche Geschichten hören.
So muss das sein.
Wir sprechen uns bestimmt noch mal.
Erst mal sehen wir uns am Donnerstag.
Wir sehen uns am Donnerstag.